75 سنة مرت وذهبت وما زال هناك
شعب محروم من أرضه ومن
أبسط حقوقه لا يزال محتلاً مقهوراً ومقتولاً لقد
صمد شعبنا بعد
المذبحة قبل أن
يصمد مرة أخرى ولكن
لن يعود القتلى إلى الحياة  إن
تلك الجروح لن تشفى أبدًا من
تأثير المجازر الإسرائيلية في غزة،
وسوف يظل محسوسًا لعقود من الزمن، وإذا
لم يتم استعادة الأمل ولم
تنتصر الحرية، فلا يمكن لأحد التنبؤ
بالفصل التالي من هذه المأساة، لكن الجميع
يعلم أنها ستكون أسوأ مثل العالم.
نرحب بالعام الجديد، تستمر المجازر في
فلسطين، يستمر الظلم،
تستمر المعاناة،
كم من الأجيال الفلسطينية يجب
أن تعاني قبل أن تتمكن أخيرًا من
العيش بحرية وكرامة وسلام
وسلام في أرض أجدادنا، نريد
أن نتوقف عن رؤية NABA الخاص بنا ينمو و  أخيرا
نكون قادرين على رؤية أطفالنا